she stood up and told white people to
get out of the student center and she
said because of their skin color that
these white students were not allowed
there and indeed some white people got
up and left and it was all recorded on a
cell phone let's watch that again Public
Service
Announcement excuse me if y'all didn't
know this is the MSC and frankly there's
just too many white people in here and
this is a space for people to color so
just be really cognizant of the space
that you're taking up because it does
make some of us poc's uncomfortable when
we see too many white people in here
it's only been open for 4 days and
frankly there's the whole university for
a lot of y'all to be at and there's very
few spaces for us so keep that in mind
thank you literally millions of college
students have been taught and many have
come to believe that white people are
inherently bigoted and evil along with
all manner of other Insidious left-wing
myths